Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Every school of thought may not agree up
to quote only say.
So when they say Quran in sunnah it may
also include z but we as Muslims we only
follow the Quran and the say hadith the
zith has its importance
you don't have to negate it completely
but as a huah as a proof as an argument
as a must to follow as a fur if you say
it's fur it can only be from Quran and
say if it if it has its own importance
two zit can come and make it into a say.
So in the say classification again the
muadi say in the classification the
compilation done by mam bkari it is said
he had memorized about 300,000 a hadith
and analyzed 600,000 a hadit out of
which he has picked up 7,563
and authenticated asah some publications
have 7,275
we have the nine volumes in English
Arabic is in one volume there are
different prints again when I say five
volumes. Oh, I got a book in three
volumes. It may change the print may
change. They may make short make five
into three. They can make five into one
also. Therefore, I mentioned the name of
the publication. So, Bkhari this Bkhari
most of the translations in English are
in nine volumes. Mudum may have six
volumes. Arabic has got only one volume.
So, please don't there are many people
who quot and tell me you know brother
okay one thing I forgot in the
translation that brother Zakir we
checked up your references of the Quran.
Alhamdulillah
95% correct but two three places you
know
wrong I said you're wrong yes I can make
a mistake I'm not saying I'm infallible
these people don't know that even in
numbering of the verses of the Quran it
wasn't revealed chapter number verse
number the ayat was revealed now when
you give references of the Quran there
are different classification of verses
the ayat is the same the Arabic word
does not a difference of even a single
alphabet
But it did not come verse number one
verse number two.
So some of the classifications have
converted one verse into two verses. So
when you read but the difference is not
when you read Surah Maida 5 when I say
maida ch that's not 90 it's actually 93.
No he's referring to another
classification.
So when you find that the reference is
missing and if it misses by one or two
you have to try and find out which
classification has he used. So even in
numbering like surah fatya some say
bismillah is one verse
some people start with alhamdulillah but
in the end it both come to seven. So
when they say bismillah is first verse
they merge the fifth or sixth or sixth
and seventh as one verse it comes as
seven. And you say bismillah is not
verse number one. Alhamdulillah is verse
number one. Yet it comes to seven
because cross reference of the Quran of
surah hij chapter number 15 verse number
87 that the off repeated seven verses.
So even in difference of opinion the
verses in surah faty had the seven but
otherwise surya has got two three verses
more. So when you give references
and you check the references, it may be
that one or two in the different Qurans
may differ.
That doesn't mean that it's a mistake.
They have used a different
classification for the verses of the
Quran.
Now coming back to the hadith
in the classification of the hadith
Imam Bkari may Allah grant him jah
his mission was to collect the sahad and
his only job was whether sah or he
collected sahad he memorized more than
300,000
and he classified as 7,275 as sahi
now in his jamya sahi
that you have here. If I quote that imam
bkari has classified the hadith say but
it's not there in the jam say
can it be true
bkari has classified hadith as say but
it's not there inside bkari can it be
possible yes or no
correct
for example in bkari there are nine
volumes so if Imam bkari has classified
certain hades so certain scholars or
certain other people they summarize
Bkari. So if it's there in the
summarize, so that may be missing in the
summary.
>> I'm saying that it's a hadith of Bkari
classified as sahi but not in the nine
volumes. Is it possible?
Who says yes raise your hand?
Im bkar classified say but not in the
sah bkari. It is possible that it it it
is not mentioned in the sahib bkari
because the sahib bkari itself is a
collection of hadith as per mention or
the sayings of prophet Muhammad himself
but whether it's authentic or not is
something that bkari himself said yeah
so it does not need to be in the
>> question you you asked
>> do you know what I'm asking you yes or
no
>> yes
>> see I'm experienced in the field
sometime ask the person knowing he knows
the answer sometime I ask knowing very
still doesn't know the answer. I asked a
question. Immari has classified it as
sahi but not there in the jam sah the
nine volumes. Is it possible?
>> It is possible.
>> How? Give an example
>> because you know I don't know.
>> It is possible is all like
>> how is possible? Give explanation. Yes
or no? Yes. 50% right.
You don't know the answer. I don't know
the exact reason.
>> Do you have knowledge of hadith?
Yes, brother Vod.
Is it possible that say Bkari is
classified as sahi and if not then the
jam say if you know raise your hand.
Don't just waste time. I'm very short of
time.
>> Okay. Because he mentioned
>> are you sure the answer is correct? Are
you sure? Then say otherwise don't say
please it. Who's sure of the answer?
Sure of the answer then raise your hand.
Let's come back to Farik.
>> Based on certain categories, Imm Bukari
has classified his hadith in say Bkari.
>> Which category?
>> There are about seven categories that he
has classified and other hadith also he
has classified it. But every scholar had
his own strictness like Imam Bkari was
the most strict when he collected
certain ais. So based on that he
compiled those hadith based on his
strictness in Bkari. There may be
certain other hades which may be in
other books which he may have not put it
based on his criteria for classification
in Sai Bkhari. So he may have
categorized in some other answer of
Farik [snorts] raise your hand.
Who agrees with his answer? Raise your
hand. 1 2 3 4 5 6. Who disagrees? Raise
your hand. Okay. The six agree. No one
disagrees. Others don't know. Correct.
You cannot know. Also what Farik said is
right. But to give you a better example
that Imam Bkari in his jamya sahi
he said I will take only had of those
narrators up to category 3. Even a
hadith narrated by category five is sah.
But he says no in my jamya I will take
narrators only up to category three.
I will not take off five. Though five
comes into the category of sah. If a
narrator number five categories of
narrators you know best then next next
12 categories in say hadith you can even
go up to category number five but he
said no I want the purest that's my
criteria for this collection so he takes
only had which are up to category number
three kalas there are other books of
Imam Bkari
which are but not so strict as jam
alkari
you understand who knew this answer
besides
You don't raise like that either raise
like that or keep it down. Okay. Three
knew. Alhamdulillah. So Imam Bkari had a
set of criteria of being extra strict.
There are certain criteria five criteria
for had to be say Bkari went to the
extent of adding more strictness. Okay
you pass in 40. No no no I want 80%
pass. So 40% is passed but in his jam
only he has taken 80%. Just to give you
an example. Say Muslim had his
additional criteria besides the five
criteria for sah he said no I take
hadith up to narrator category number
four but the criteria of strictness of
Imam Muslim was less than bkari but
there were some criteria which imam
Muslim used which bkari didn't use
so among the strict compilers of the
hadith the strictest is bkari stricter
than others
but he has said it is sah but not up to
this level say
But not distinction goes into the other
books. So there are books written by
Bkari and compiled hadith which are sah
but not falling in the nine volumes.
Nine volumes of English translation. Udu
has six, Arabic has one. So don't go on
volumes but the main compilation. Is it
clear? So you as a person of knowledge
should know these things. Now there are
people who said oh bkari has quoted
zadis. Are there any zad in Bkari?
In this book say [snorts] Bkari. Are
there any zad?
Who says no? Raise your hand.
No zid. Not a single in this book I'm
carrying. Raise your hand.
1 2 3 4 5 6. Who says there are zadies?
Raise your hand.
Full or down? No.
He's a friend from Jamal imllham.
[music and singing]
[music]
Allah.
Foreman
speech.